I think you disagree with this but I
think the protests and them asking for
either defunding or abolishing the
police is a good place to start Sam what
the what is going on here I feel it's a
great place to stuff okay let's have
this discussion defund the police yes
defund the police okay why would you
want to make them less fun what is what
is what is defunding the police break it
down because at the surface anybody
hears that it's realistic yes right and
calls the police anybody it's like I'm
gonna call the police
it was like don't defund them yeah so
break it down maybe it's something that
we don't understand two different things
so there's one group asking to defund
the police as in take away funds because
they're their practices haven't been
like for the people and redistribute
those funds to other things like
community leadership or counseling or
things of that nature like just
different ways to police the the
community yep then there's people who
want complete defunding like like almost
abolishing it right and starting anew so
let's let's do uh let's start with the
first one which i think is like the most
realistic one that a lot of people are
which is basically and mark clarify this
because we had this discussion before
which is like from and if I'm saying
something wrong correct me but right now
the police do a lot of jobs that aren't
necessarily policing correct for example
like if there's a homeless people doing
something wrong right the police will be
sent there instead of maybe like a
counselor that might be better equipped
with how to deal with a crazy person and
they could help
my cousin is a psychiatrist and he's
like police don't go [ __ ] they just drop
them off at the hospital they're like
here you go and then they get out right
look [ __ ] so so they go like okay that's
a perfect example and then maybe like
suicide is another situation where the
police will go there but maybe again you
could have a different division where
you'll have counselors go there and help
right yeah um hostage negotiation I'm
sure there's like a hostage expert there
but you might also call the police so I
think the defunding thing the idea is
and it's poorly worded but instead of
going take instead of defunding the
police you're basically going why don't
we just use the police for what they're
supposed to do and then use other
experts for these fields yes for what
they are supposed to do a couple other
things are like the DNA testing sex kits
rape kits and stuff like that yeah cuz
all those stuff tend to be really backed
up in most places right and then the
police claim oh we don't have the
funding we don't have then let you
another edition just do them so that'd
be interesting about defunding I think
that's why if we had a different word
people who digest it way better
so the pushback that I would give to
that this is what I've read is how that
helps save black people they're talking
about so let me just make the point is
like all these divisions that are
talking about defunding aren't when
police kill black people right one
second so it's like black people aren't
homeless when they're getting killed by
the police right black people aren't
crazy when they're getting povo killed
by the police blackberry what other
things they do it's not DNA kits or sex
kits the black people are getting killed
by the police the places where black
people are getting killed by the police
or in the violent crime situations -
pullovers the stops now I would disagree
with that
give me one that's not Floyd he was
called for a counterfeit bill but you
need police for that you can send like
an auxiliary cop that doesn't need a gun
for
for like type of like financial fraud
situations yeah like it's you I think
police should be there for violent
situations if a guy is just like oh he's
trying to counterfeit bill let's just
call you you know how they have like
take a cops backup outside of that right
outside of that we can look at a lot of
these scenarios and a lot of these
situations where cops have killed
innocent black people and they aren't in
this
situations which they're saying that
they should defund and I would probably
go so far as to say 99% of the times
where innocent black people are killed
by the police they're not in those
slivers of policing that they want to
defund so I don't know if that
functionally helps the problem that's
the pushback I would yeah but I'm saying
the people who are acting for that they
just want police for violent situations
and those are the situations where they
unlawfully kill blacks so why don't like
violence situations like a robbery like
shoot out somewhere and solve that a
counterfeit bill a selling a loose
cigarette these aren't things where a
soft with a gun is speeding is what he's
saying yeah getting pulled over this
flannel Castillo is just that the
routine traffic Scott yo Loki so back up
you don't even need a D front why does a
highway cop I'm trying to think of
scenario you know what they're gonna say
poke holes in my our poke holes in my
argument but why does a routine highway
cop not I'm not just routine I wake up
why is it that why do they have to have
a gun if you're just given tickets they
are gonna say in a way the number one
way cops get killed is routine traffic
stops I need to have my gun you are
putting us in danger to which kind of I
would be like yeah you've knew that when
you signed up for this job it's a
dangerous job that's what they tell cops
in Europe ever me let me just poke a
hole my own argument sometimes you pull
someone over and then they have drugs in
the car and they don't want to get
caught with those drugs so then they
start shooting it's there and then it
becomes a bigger type of crime yeah and
a lot of like smaller things escalate
quickly because of the person that's
involved that person might be some mafia
dude that's got [ __ ] kilo cocaine in
the back he's like I'm not going to jail
for 25 years boom boom boom
but you just pulled him over cuz he's
speeding and so I would say I think
those occurrences happen a lot less than
a normal traffic stop yeah
so for those situations if all the
people are aware like it's almost like
how a lot of London most cops don't have
guns people are aware that the cops
don't have guns so things don't tend to
escalate if I also don't have guns ready
design an armed Republic where America
is but I'm saying like so safe
drug dealer knows like oh the traffic
cop doesn't really have a gun that I
don't really need to shoot him to get
away I can just run away and then that
person just hauls in the actual please
be like yo this person ran and I
suspected something
now the police can come in for a
situation like that before a routine
traffic stop you don't need to have this
hot this police officer who's been
trained in combat training
who's first thought is like oh I got to
protect myself at all cost like and I
could be in danger in a split second
because we're trained to react not even
know we're trained to anticipate and
that's one of the problems in like the
way we're trained like as a law
enforcement person it's like we have to
anticipate that is gonna be danger and
then don't hesitate to react on it and
that's what goes wrong half the time
it's a split decision where someone's
like complaining about the way cops talk
to you during a traffic stop and you're
like you're not trying to de-escalate
anything you're just trying to ask like
you know I pulled you over what makes
you think you're better than everybody
else that you can just speed and they
can't and it's like it's just not
anything that could happen is just
escalating right I mean and if you have
people that were trained and
de-escalating just writing the ticket
hey man I got to do this sorry it is
what it is like and then if we need to
search the car call for backup whatever
you're not to wait here and then one of
the like the tertiary benefits is that
you can have like military police or
like actual violent police like police
that are dealing with violence are able
to get like more specifically trained
trained for longer and you're able to
allocate more money into a smaller
subset well not police but tip to
shelters point where you're [ __ ] up
marketing-wise is saying defunding the
police it's such every report is oh I'm
in danger and that's but that's how you
don't market headlines but back back up
it's not only Republicans I think the
average person sees the word defund
police and they go well I don't want a
police force that's so depleted that
they can't protect me is that reasonable
is that what you guys thought when you
first saw this is I personally think is
a problem with like liberal academia is
that they will work through all of the
problems and then come up with solutions
and then present the solutions and they
sound crazy so like for example they're
like oh like everyone has to acknowledge
their white privilege and it's like what
you're saying my life is easy and it's
like no no no I've actually just been
thinking
like you know we've been studying
sociology for you know 50 years were
like oh yeah white people just do the
virtue of your skin you have an easier
time blah blah blah and so now you have
to acknowledge like the whole
explanation of it yes so they come up
with they solve the problems over years
and years and years and then they come
up with the solution that is just like a
headline and it sounds crazy as opposed
to what as opposed to like okay here's
the problem or like yeah but that's that
can't be add line exactly so the issue
is that like they want to be things they
want to make waves with it and they know
it's gonna be spread around and they
know that this idea is gonna be shared
by everybody and now it's this common
goal it sounds sexy and you jump behind
a sexy idea it's no different than what
Trump does it's like it's just it's
super interesting
[Applause]